I'd like to welcome you to the
communications forum for this thursday
i'm david Thorburn professor of
literature and director of the MIT
communications forum i'm especially
excited about today's event Marty and
Martin marks was the moderator and and
organizer of this event has been talking
about a project of this kind to me for a
long time and I'm very happy it's
finally come to fruition Marty will
explain will introduce his speakers and
set the parameters of his discussion but
I would like first to remind folks that
there is one final forum scheduled for
this semester it's listed on the website
as you can see and it actually serves as
the inaugural event or opening event of
a conference of the 6th annual the 6th
biannual biannual mean every two years I
hope so because that's what I mean
there's 6th the 6th media in transition
conference you can find out about it on
the website there's a I hope many of you
who are not already registered to attend
will choose to do so and that final for
the final forum is on April 23rd a
thursday at our usual time but it's in a
different space as you can see to link
it to the conference events which will
follow on Friday Saturday and Sunday and
we have a it's a very interesting
conference which I think we've had we
had something like almost 300 applicants
to deliver papers at the conference and
a significant proportion of them I think
more than half are from abroad so it's
the most internationally diverse
conference we've ever we've ever run and
it should be quite an exciting event
there is no admission fee I hope some of
you in the audience will make the time
to attend some of the events and there's
a full agenda for the events both the
great large plenary public conversations
we're planning as well as a series of
smaller breakout sessions in which
individual scholar
we'll deliver short papers on topics
connected to the theme of the conference
so I urge all of you to look at that if
you can it's it's now a great pleasure
for me to introduce my my friend my
longtime friend and colleague professor
martin marks who teaches in the music
and theatre arts section at MIT and has
been since its inception a mainstay of
the Media Studies program at MIT Martin
Marty Marty is the author of a
pioneering book on on film music called
music and the silent film from Oxford in
1997 and more recently he's engaged in a
scholarly project that may have even
greater impact in that wonderful book
it's a series of DVDs that he's
collaborating with collaborating with
other scholars on the first three sets
which he wrote notes for concerning the
music is called treasures from the from
the American Film Archives and the first
three sets were published over the
period two thousand feet from the years
two thousand to two thousand seven more
more subsets of the series are planned
and one such devoted to the silent
Western film is one that Marnie has
already begun to work on and it's a it's
an immensely illuminating and powerful
series because the notes alone are worth
the price of admission but of course you
can also watch these silent films and
watch them with musical accompaniment
much of which Marty has helped to create
and organize so he's been working in
this field for a considerable time
himself and his a real has major
standing in the field of film music and
as you'll see the colleagues he's
gathered around him have at least an
equal claim on our attention Marty marks
thank you David I'm delighted to be here
and I'm really delighted to be here with
Paul and Dan my panelists our panelists
who are both very distinguished and I
want to introduce them to you myself in
just a moment I wanted to start by
picking up on some of David's own
pioneering work in return for thanking
improved for his nice introduction of me
david has for a long time run
conferences and classes under the
heading media in transition and this has
been one of the key themes of media
studies at MIT and I've been thinking
about how to introduce this panel on
film music and digital media and I
started to think about the the concept
of media and transition and it just
seems to me that there's no way to talk
about film as an art form and as a
technological form without talking about
it as a media in perpetual state of
transition there is no such thing as a
stable medium called film it has been
constantly changed from year to year
from decade to decade sometimes almost
from month to month or day to day in
terms of the technological tools that
drive the medium and in that respect my
own work has long focused primarily at
one end of the history of film the
silent film with live musical
accompaniment and in working in that
area my original experiences were to
take scores or create scores of my own
and play them live to silent film to try
to recreate the experience of silent
film and live music as it was developed
during the primarily during the teens
and 20s although it goes back to the
1890s in some respects but with the
coming of the DVD project especially
it's like I've leapfrogged to the other
end of the history of the media
because now I'm sitting there recording
scores for DVDs with time-coded film
I've got an engineer up in the booth
with pro tools and all the other things
I've got crashing technology every 10
minutes which interrupts the scores that
I'm trying to prepare or record or
practice I've got all those things going
on and I feel like I'm getting this
medium from both ends or working the
medium from both ends and it's driven
home to me more than ever what a
fascinating and rich medium film is and
film music because of this constantly
changing digital environment that we're
in today which is only an extension of
the changes before in fact there's a
tendency to theorize the history of
sound and film by talking about two
revolutions in film sound the first
sound revolution is of course the coming
of the technology of sound recording to
film in the mid to late 20s and the
crisis that that provoked the transition
that that provoked to a brand-new in a
way way of making films designing them
for sound as well as image the second
sound revolution as it's often called
today was the one that began in the late
60s but really occurred during the 70's
and its really the revolution more from
the aesthetic point of view as much or
at least as much from the aesthetic
point of view as from the technological
point of view it's the revolution in
sound design it's the idea that we
suddenly start to talk about people like
Walter Murch as key creative figures in
the making of film now this is their
long been people who are vital to
concerned and film you can go back in
the history but there's a new awareness
of sound technology and of sounds
potential in the 70s so that really
changed the way people heard movies and
saw movies tremendously now of course
we're in the third revolution which i
think is a revolution that will never
stop it as long as their new digital
innovations I certainly don't feel that
this panel can talk about a stable new
world of film music that things have
changed and we want to try to freeze the
frame for
few minutes and talk about what's
happening now and how things have
changed from both the very far past and
the more recent past of film scoring
techniques so with that that's my
overview right now and I want to turn to
Paul first and dance second but let me
introduce them together first of all as
far as Paul johar is concerned he's an
old friend of mine we've we've known
each other for many years and so we are
buddy buddy and we're going to treat
each other like that but he is also a
very distinguished person in the field
he is now the chair of visual media at
UCLA that is he runs their graduate film
music program and he's taught off and on
at UCLA in the past but now he's got
this full-time job which is taking up
more time than he wants I think because
he still got a lot of other things to do
over the decades since the 70s he's
composed at least a hundred film scores
and music for many TV series he's worked
with directors such as luton
distinguished directors such as Sidney
Lumet Arthur Penn Louis Malle and John
Turturro his credits in the in the in
his younger days his credits included
some really interesting films that are
under appreciated for their music which
is often the case Prince of the city
crossing delancey the morning after
which has a marvelous score I've always
had a soft spot for that movie and the
TV series china beach but he's also got
some other interesting credits that
people are not apt to know about he's a
member of the team of four that first
produced the American versions of
Miyazaki's animated features for Walt
Disney including cocoa posing the score
for a film called Kiki's Delivery
Service and he's a member of the he was
our he received the award of composer of
the year from the classical recording
foundation in 2009 in fact as much as
he's done in the world of film he's done
a tremendous amount of concert music and
in fact there's a world premiere of his
fiola concerto next month with the
Cleveland Orchestra so he's busy on many
fronts and I wish I could mention all
his film scores now let's go to Dan very
quickly because Dan is the as far as I
can see there's no more important figure
in the music editing world of film
scoring today he's his current title
right now since 2007 is chair of film
scoring at Berklee College of Music just
across the river and if you know your
film score you know that Berkeley is
turning out major composers all the time
now or bicoastal they're going from here
to Hollywood and making major careers
from 2004 to 2007 he was executive
director of the Mancini institute of los
angeles which has become an important
kind of foundational source of money and
support for film composers from two
thousand three to five he was chair of
the board of trustees of the grammys
organization the Recording Academy and
from 1982 2003 he's was the chief
executive officer of segue music in LA
which is the industry's largest provider
of music supervisors super super vision
and music editing services so even if
you don't see his name on the film's his
hand has been in them in one way or
another and he's also an entity Emmy
award-winning music editor nominated for
music direction for conducting he's
worked on several award-winning films
including the Black Stallion an officer
and a gentleman the temptations what
love got to do with it and last of the
mohicans and he's going to talk a little
later about one technical area that he
did some some groundbreaking work in
during the beta testing of Pro Tools
systems he he was working he directed
that testing or he oversaw the first
digital delivery of music soundtracks of
a motion picture for the with the
creator of that digidesign so he can
tell us a lot about technical aspects
these are very busy men and I'm really
grateful for them to come in
over here and taking their time too it's
one of the reasons I've had so much
trouble getting together a film music
panel my dream panel of five composers
and five editors is because they're all
too damn busy and I was just like
they're never going to happen so we have
to take what we get but I'm really glad
we got what we've taken so without
further ado I'd like to have Paul
started yes I should have reminded you
the first hour is conversation the
second hour is talk with you with
questions and back and forth so we won't
get all our points made there'll be
plenty of things for you to ask about
and so we've got to move on to Paul
because he's got some wonderful material
to present to us and if he's going to
focus first on King Kong the recent
version with the score by James Newton
Howard but I thought him before he did
that to appreciate some of the points
he's making and to appreciate the point
I was making about film music and film
being in perpetual transition I'd like
to show you one brief clip from the 1933
King Kong because he's going to show us
how that clip was reworked and how music
plays a role in sound plays a role in
the new versions approach to the same
sequence this of course is the 1933 King
Kong a landmark of special effects in
the visual sense and also a landmark of
soundtrack making both in terms of
technology and in terms of the aesthetic
results there were two figures who were
Keef pioneers in this soundtrack one was
Murray Spivak the sound editor who had
to make up sounds that had never been
made up before how do you make an Apes
roar you know when he's 200 feet tall or
whatever he is what does it sound like
what it was footsteps sound like and
then Mack Steiner had to write a score
for this fantasy this weird bizarre this
weird fantasy of a trip to a
non-existent Skull Island where these
non-existent natives do their strange
dances
have their savage rituals of sacrifice
to the giant ape this is the sequence
where Kong first appears it comes about
30 minutes into the film there's been a
long build-up of suspense in the number
of ways and it's at this point that the
music and the sound effects really start
to take over there's been a long series
of subdued music and before that the
first 15 20 minutes of the film after
the opening credits there's no music
until we get to the unreal world of
Skull Island the realistic scenes don't
have music Steiner was originally was
very shrewd in conceiving that approach
nobody never tried a score for you know
a score that didn't start with the
picture and just roll through it he knew
when to bring the music in when Kong
appears he uses his big theme for Kong
which is basically Bom Bom Bom that's it
but that's the kong theme and it's very
elemental but you'll hear a lot of other
things including a gong and a lot of
screaming let's watch this
you
you
so a lot of music going on there the mix
is crewed by today's standards but it's
and there's that awkward moment of dead
air or dead sound when they're waiting
for the gong to be played but maybe that
makes the gong more effective you can
you can look at that in different ways
but Paul now can tell us about the new
king kong by Peter Jackson Wow can you
hear me am I on hi my name is Paul how
are you I think it's wonderful that we
thought King Kong as a touchstone for
this 1933 you know what else happened in
1933 obviously right someone named Adolf
became chancellor of germany and that
precipitated the tragedy in europe was a
blessing for our culture and certainly
for our film world i don't want to say
that there's a trade-off but
historically that's an interesting point
because many of the composers who fled
that tragedy became charter members of
this brand new art form that was
developing in california notice they
didn't come to new york as you would
have expected they went where they could
find work and so that the first
generation of great composers in
hollywood many of them were Jewish and
all of them were classically trained
composers who brought with them their
artistic sensibility born in the
vanished so / so for example when
korngold did Robin Hood for many the
great score of Hollywood he didn't try
to make the score sound English any more
than they tried to make Earl Flynn have
an English accent he wrote a score that
sounds more like rosenkavalier than
Sherwood Forest to our benefit so we
created that they created a kind of
music that we call Hollywood but come
straight from the great days of the
Vienna Staatsoper and King Kong
therefore inherited this wonderful style
from mex Steiner who was corn goats
friend and compatriot also from the
Vienna sober and it's not surprising
that he created a movie that once King
Kong is introduced in that sequence is
wall-to-wall music and it's filled with
light motifs all right so here's a score
now there was another movie intervening
on King
as you know the bridges jeff bridges in
the 70s this score by jon barry i know
the score very well because i was the
composer in those days they would
compete we would compete for pictures
and I was the last composer who didn't
get it I hate him no we were both
members of Carol faith studios at that
time so anyway I want you to see
something now from the very recent
picture by Peter Jackson director write
the score by a very very good composer
name is James Newton Howard he helped me
present this to you I'd like you to see
the same scene that you just saw a
loving reproduction of it by very great
i think filmmaker and look at this is
what the composer gets it's very
intimidating imagine you're the composer
hired to do a film this is what you get
here is a work print all right cut to
time the only son you're going to hear
is the original production track which
means the sound that they make while
they're filming it itself all of this is
going to be replaced in post-production
there are some temporary sounds put in
as a guide through the composer so John
if you would let's hear track one
by the wall Thanks so that's interesting
isn't it you see there on a huge sound
stage with a big screen the blue screen
behind them the picture has been cut to
time now I'm going to go right away to
the next stage of this and we'll talk a
little bit since this is kind of an
electoral acoustic seminar is it not
about how digitally sound is enhanced
you're going to hear it what we put is
called a demo or a track that the
composer is required to present this is
a whole new development in in in how
pictures I made it we can talk about how
it affects the composer but what I want
you to see is how it's here is how the
score sounds in a in a form that's
completely digitally realize or no
acoustic instruments at all in what
you're going to hear all right and the
composer is nowadays required to present
this to the to the filmmaker all right
many of you will say it already sounds
like an orchestra or some of you may say
it doesn't sound like an orchestra let's
see but this is his digitally produced
score and you won't hear any dialogue
this time you'll just see the score with
picture
you
notice the director has made some
choices that are quite interesting for
example you don't see King Kong's face
until right at the end and when you do
finally see it it's clearly a point of
view shot the perspective is such that
the only person you can see that these
is my favorite actress naomi watts and
then the reaction shots of the director
and the ship's captain and these people
is filled with horror the other one the
only reaction shots you see are the
natives who are a name you know so it
pulls us emotionally into the picture in
a different way in a very real sense
these point of view shots make us part
of the action now I'm tempted I want to
depart from the format to ask you what
you thought of the score but we'll wait
for the second hour but most people when
they hear that will say why do you need
an orchestra now the one of the things
that you have to understand is a sampled
orchestra the sound source is acoustic
to begin with right now the next version
you're going to here then is the
acoustic Orchestra itself now the thing
to remember about the acoustic orchestra
is that it also is very large 80 to 100
pieces depending on which session you
are at and they are not playing wild
that is the conductor's not conducting
freely as in the good old days when i
worked at Warner Brothers for so many
years the orchestra is actually playing
to the basic tracks of the track you
just heard those things are laid down
first for the obvious reason that with
Pro Tools and with avid these various
computers you can set the score to the
picture it actually makes the role of
the music editor which was so essential
a different kind of mechanical
interaction between composer film and
you know so wait but we are dependent on
this gentleman here without him I'm
nothing and with him I'm still nothing
well can you clarify the entire music
mix of in track number three it is
acoustic what we are going to hear is
the acoustic score you're not going to
hear any samples all right and it's
essentially the same score but it's
going to be exactly in sync with the
previous one and two picture because
picture came first digital score came
next acoustics car came after that all
they done to the same try to the same
not with click now but with the music
track alright so here we go
you
you
good all right I will wind up this
portion by showing you the final version
which is in Hollywood is called the dub
the dub is that stage where you mix
together all of the sound elements in
post-production which are of course
music dialogue often replaced and
enhanced and sound effects sometimes
called Foley alright so this is the dub
by the way I've mentioned that because
in the East Coast when I first started
working here Sidney Lumet another New
York people call it the final mix to me
that was always confusing because mix to
me means a purely recording stage but
here is the version with the dub now
they're going to be some artistic
decisions made by the director that were
different from that which the composer
made look music is the same but you'll
see it the music is dipped at a few
places where you want the dialogue to
come through and you can see his the
decisions that were made now I want the
music that you hear music still drives
the scene is a mixture of the sound
effect for get I said son it's a mixture
of the music track that the digital
music tracks you heard and the acoustic
and in the old days when when we were
recording on everything to 35 millimeter
third 35 millimeter stock has four
stripes of information we called them
stripes one of them was always allocated
to the electronic codes called the sim
time code which locked the various
elements together in other words when we
were mixing they were locked together
electronically not mechanically so one
of the four stripes was allocated to the
sim t time code the other three were for
music generally this way pad rhythm
section and melody which was very
convenient for the rock and roll music
of the 60s where you had basically a
rhythm guitar and lead guitar in a pad
so but and in larger productions you
might have three or four or five
different tracks of music coming in and
these would all have three stripes right
I remember the first time I heard about
somebody doing 24 tracks that seemed
quite elaborate in the old days studios
had 24 tracks too
right then later they had two of those
tables you have 48 and that was for this
movie they used a thousand tracks music
not not of not of double all the other
elements thousand tracks six complete
protool sessions now I don't mean by
that that some of them were just a
single they were like guitars and
everything out it's it's a world that
only a digital digital technical and I
didn't mean I don't mean a team of four
hundred people in the digital world he
had two mixers I mean two people on his
staff and one over word secretary who
kept a lot of all of these things it is
the exponential expansion of how these
things work from the analog world to the
digital world is scary and it's for the
young I'm too old to learn this you
people the you it's a brave new world
and you're going to inherit it but if
you need an Orchestrator hun we're all
young at heart so it's for all of us so
here is the final one and
Oh
up
behind the wall
thank you Paul very much for those
forklift for taking the time to put
those together and I by indirect
indirectly thanks to James Newton Howard
for giving them to you I want to make
one quick comment before I pass it over
just looking at it now I changed my mind
about something that point of view shot
of King Kong's eyes I don't think that's
Naomi Watts point of you she's obviously
not doubt it's the directors isn't it
they're looking that they're making eye
contact it's a scary moment it's funny
how he personalized this is director I
think it's a very good director he loved
obviously loved the original it's it's a
it's a kind of labor of love but he
added these own special touches i think
yes that shelter there's a lot of things
we could talk about in that regard but i
want to i want to move it actually there
are so many things going on in that last
version that Alyssa Alyssa different
responses from any of the other versions
I'm going to throw one out i know that i
want to hold most of it for you people
to talk about but my my reaction to the
reaction shots in versions two and three
was to feel what great actors they were
in Jack Black and aidan quinn and others
because they I'm sorry hey Brody brought
Adrien Brody because somehow those high
sustained sounds really intensified
those shots in a way that I felt made
their emotions more visceral or more
vivid to me as I what they were
projecting which but basically they're
just looking at something that they're
not even seeing yes they're actors
pretending to see something so it's
interesting to me that in the final mix
he chose not to play up the music for
those shots but to play up the sound
effects that's one of the many choices
and that that's going to lead me to you
Dan partly because I assume that as an
editor supervisor type person you're
going to have a lot of the way you get
from one of those stages to the next
involves you to a tremendous amount or
music editorial work and I'm curious to
know both how you see that sec that
sequence of clips
from a professional point of view and
and you know you talk about your own
experiences in that regard if you like
well it's a thank you very much more to
be the thing that would be interesting
for me to know is if there was a temp
score that they laid in which the music
editor would have done prior to to
change doing that no well that's great
that's that's that's what that's what
one hopes for can you hear me all right
so thank you the the challenge for music
editors these days aside from all the
technical stuff that we didn't have to
know prior to the 1990s really is in
creating a temp score so we would that
that first version of music that you
heard we're of james's electronic stuff
most of the time what's required is for
a music editor to create that from
existing music that's already been
recorded elsewhere on other movies what
what's really great is if we can
convince the director not to do that and
just to sit tight so that the composer
can come up with something and the
reason that's not the reason that's good
the two reasons one is as music I'd you
don't have to do that it's really hard
to take music that was written for some
other film uniquely and then try and
make it fit into somebody's new unique
film there's just no matter how well you
temp track a movie no matter how well
you find other music and cut it up and
combine tracks or what not to make it
work it's never going to be as good as
what a composer here could do from top
to bottom because it each movie is
unique and different so he said
redundantly so so in this kind of a
search so that's that's a one thing so
from the music editors point of view
that's that sort of great the second
thing is is that it by allowing the
composer to create something new rather
than well here let me say we have a tent
we have a term called demo love and that
is that you can imagine a music eter it
you've made this film and then you come
to
you say okay Paul is going to score it
but in the meantime we want to show it
to the producer in the studio and other
folks so what I want you to do mr. music
editor is to create a temp score for me
okay so I do that and it takes me three
or four weeks to do that and then but
the film is changing all the time so
they're looking at it all the time with
the music in it and finally after five
or six or seven weeks we'd of it and we
have a screening will show it to the
producers and they give us notes and
then we go back make film changes and I
have to then adjust the temp track I've
created and then we go out and we show
it to a public audience I don't know if
they do this in Boston in new york and
california or LA area it's you
frequently will go to moving there'll be
somebody outside saying hey you want to
go to a free movie on tuesday night see
comedy starring somebody or an action
film song and so so we we have the
screening so people come in like you
would go into the theater and you just
take notes and and we take your notes
from you and say you know yeah it would
say you know rate how you like the movie
action how did you like the characters
how about the pace you know all that
kind of stuff and people love to think
that their opinion matters so so people
are happy to do that so anyway now okay
so by now the composer's live or the
director and everybody else has lived
with the temp score that I created and
now it's time to 810 weeks down the line
for the composer now to create or to
record his score and so he will give
mock-ups like you heard the electronic
mock-ups of james version here and
what's very difficult is for the
composer or for the director to remove
him or herself from the temp track that
he or she has fallen in love with now
and has become part of the movie i mean
it becomes like an actor's voice so now
in comes Paul with a whole new approach
and many times this is where composers
get fired so composers now have to say
okay
how you know I have to get close enough
to this temp track so that it's not
radically different for the director but
I have to be I want to give it my own
individual artistic input and I also
don't want to get sued as has happened
in Hollywood when composers didn't get
far enough away from the original temp I
you know that's that's the dilemma that
the composer finds himself in so what
you'll so so the proof in the pudding
here is that for a long time in the 90s
you were getting a lot of generic scores
you would get a generic action score
action-adventure score you get a generic
romantic comedy score generic in the
sense that a lot of us music etters
would temp these saw these movies with
the same great scores you know that that
that had become popular and so then a
composer would come along and the
director would say this is what I like
Paul give me this this is just you know
do your thing but I really love this and
so everything starts sounding alike
that's how you get all these things to
sound alike so anyway that's the
long-winded answer to your question on
that of course but there's a the temp
track problem coming there there are
famous anecdotes and one of them was
when Alex North went to the screening of
2001 discovered that his score wasn't
there and nobody had bothered to tell
him that Kubrick had replaced it with
the original temp track that he used now
I think that's an impossible story I
think it's a great story but I don't
believe it a word of it but that's
another another story the point is that
this idea of temp tracking has been
around at least in the minds of some of
those directors who want their own
authority to be imposed on the whole of
the film Chaplin is another who wouldn't
would insist on being the musician
somehow in charge of the score even
though he couldn't write music like
Clint Eastwood today like clan toys yeah
who wants his own little piano doodling
stew become to score but and maybe it's
the right approach maybe it's not you
could let's take a vote but why is it
that what what's happened is that the
new the new digital technology has made
it so easy it happens you've got
library in your computer of all the
great scores you can just pull them up
at will you don't have to even go down
the the office corridor to the record
library and pull them up and do called
through all the laborious process of
transferring by the way then nowadays
the director will work directly with his
film editor because we're all using the
same computers anyway the pro tools for
sound and avid for picture and in effect
the director makes his own temp track
many time jump and it's a day of time
yeah and the other thing that's
happening is that because music one of
the music of today allows itself to be
tempted whether easily for example when
american beauty came out with the score
by newman Tommy Thomas Newman that was
so popular and is a you know it was he
himself would admit it was generic post
minimalism that he was writing a scarves
influenced by Michael Gordon and post
Steve Reich and this sort of marimbas
mallet sound non melodic that if that
kind of music is very easy to edit on a
computer basis it's much harder to edit
something by Jerry Goldsmith or you know
that has rubato in it for example and
that's not composed to a click track it
you try cutting that I know you can do
it yours I've seen him he doesn't magic
but that's a different kind of good
that's a different kind of problem it's
much much easier now if I could just
tell the other side of that flip story
of the Alex North story my friend who
since passed away George de la rue an
academy award-winning composer that Paul
also knew and it was friendly with you
work together in fact you actually
recorded my score for prince of the city
right the Paris Opera Orchestra right
after they recorded the three-act
version of Lulu which was discovered in
the late 80s and that's why that score
sounds so wonderful so yeah my music
it's the orchestra well so George and
his wife Colette go to the to the movies
one weekend to see the color purple and
they you know right in the middle of the
main title I turn and look at each other
because this is Georges theme from a
film called my mother's house and what
had happened
is that Quincy Jones had been hired to
put this all together he put a group of
13 composers together and Steven
Spielberg wanted what they called
Polaroids in which were just temp cues
and as they would try as then when they
hired the person when when Quincy and
his group went to go and record they
mocked a kind of they kind of mimicked
George's music but not you know they
thought they were safe but Steven kept
wanting so the story goes so I've heard
Steven kept wanting him to do more and
more like the temp so they did it so
much like the temp that George and and
and Capitol Records sued the because
capital is the publisher they sued and
George said he made more money on that
score then he made on any other score he
ever did but you know the funny thing is
that score still won the Academy Award
well it was nominated yeah yeah didn't
win but those of us who run the voting
exciting member of it we didn't know to
whom to give the score 13 people yang
the Dirty Dozen we called them yet what
wasn't there a film just this last year
that couldn't be nominated because there
were too many names yes this happens all
the time and it was a good score to the
the issue though here is is a strange
one of control because of the new
digital the power of digital tools right
the fact that Pro Tools exists for
anybody to use that as you said the
director can the director can do what
Kubrick did so much easier he can become
a quote composer and so you you and what
else has changed why is it that so you
have the power to do it but why is it
that people now are no longer willing to
trust the composer to give him the time
that's needed to come up with his own
ideas is it I mean Peter Jackson
obviously was willing to trust power
well yes and no he'd Howard Peter
Jackson's first choice for King Kong was
not James Newton Howard it was Howard
Shore wasn't it who between yes and I
were to give it and we had just done
Lord of the Rings and then they were
they'd worked on it for like three
months and all of a sudden Howard sure
was gone and we in Hollywood were we
heard the story which none of us
they said that there was a difference of
opinion now but nobody believes that
these two had worked together forever
they had just done Lord of the Rings how
could there be a Concord to be a
creative difference after three months
but in any way James Newton Howard had
three I have my theory about that by the
way better James Newton Howard did the
score in three weeks and all of them
have told me in preparing for this
lecture by the way I want you to know
how flattered and honored we both feel
about being here in this August hall you
know my parents thought I was a complete
[ __ ] would never month anything in
here i am at MIT you finally made it
here so um they when I ask my colleagues
would you help me put together this
presentation they all cooperated with
they were so pleased I mean I'm going to
drop a few other names other composers
like Mike post law and order and so
forth everybody's delighted to have this
presentation here but they told me one
thing that I want to share with you they
are all required to make demos now well
you know what we used to call temps now
they call them demos or mock-ups they
want to make them very good because
we're not they'll get thrown out on the
other hand they know that if they're too
good that'll become the score I can tell
you that's what happened at Paramount
about four years ago whatever start Trek
generation we were in at the time they
the producer was requiring mock-ups from
the composer and one day David Grossman
who says at that time was the senior
vice president of music for television
at Paramount so he was the top guy for
music there got a call from the producer
and producer said I just got the latest
mock ups and you know what this stuff is
good enough now and so I want you to
take the orchestra out of the budget no
more Orchestra no more recording
sessions and because that was really the
last major show on television that
paramount was doing they shut down the
lot they close down the scoring stage
and and moved the music you know what
few music people they still had off of
the line I had a very similar experience
with a great director Sidney Lumet with
whom certainly this is one of the old
tours of our industry and he did a
serious a few years ago called 100
center street but the same
creative team that had created law and
order which is one of only two shows by
the way shot and conceived entirely in
New York and for that reason I'm very
grateful to that show and considered
truly authentic but I wrote a theme for
it that called for a high trumpet all
right for whatever reason and I did it
digitally of course but I said wait till
you hear the real version because the
real version i had gotten Phil Smith
who's a principal in trumpet of the New
York Philharmonic a great virtuoso and
we recorded it I thought this was
sensational but he had fallen in love
with the digital we already did that we
recorded it we paid for it and all the
rest a completely acoustic version but
the version you hear on television is
with the my original demo track and I
was at a conference back in i guess i
was around 1999-2000 was not too long
ago hell elmer bernstein died in 2004 i
think it's very 2004 and but he was
still very active in certain kinds
because of the return of certain genres
he was called back after years of
relative obscurity even though he's such
a great composer and I heard him speak
at a conference in with incredible
frustration and anger and he said you
know I've had a few years experience in
this business and yet i'm still being
asked to go on saturday to the producers
house and to my demo score my mock up
i'm not going to do that anymore if they
don't want if they don't trust me i'm
not going to score there can you use to
do expletives but up but and I I was I
was very moved by this because it was
here you were looking at one of the
geniuses of American film music who has
reduced to this partly because of the
technological capabilities of the medium
as they've changed it may have happened
of course we're ignoring the economic
realities which is there's so much money
riding on these films that they're
afraid to take risks unfortunately and
that the the old studio system for all
of its faults and flaws had a lot more
there were a lot of people like Alfred
Newman around and said give this guy a
chance give David wrexham the chance to
write the score for Laura before you use
sophisticated lady right which is by the
way a musical that Paul did arranging
for so I had to get that in because
by Duke Ellington yeah so let's i think
it is 602 and there's a paul has a lot
more material that including some of his
own but he has he does have clips from
Law & Order Diaz clips from the NCI and
you also have a whole set of things for
blood diamond that are similar to what
you saw which is a very different
musical style but I wonder if we
shouldn't at least now see if you have
some questions or comments on what
you've been hearing and seeing first and
then we can go back to some more
material if we have the time does that
sound reasonable David that a good idea
so who wants to ask a question who make
a comment please hold hands up or shout
them out so we can see me oh you have to
come to the mics which are on both sides
halfway down yes please did they have to
introduce themselves dude all right
you'd be helpful if you tell us who you
are oh I know who I am yes isn't there
we go my name is Paul where man i teach
film scoring and know what trying to
music over at tufts and I'm enjoying
this very very much hearing this this
side of things 1 comment i wanted i
wanted to make was it will you talking
about temp tracks a lot of the directors
that I end up working with cut their
film to the temp track and so you end up
having to absorb the tempos and the the
structure anyway whether you want to or
not I'm sure you've come across that but
here's a question that's something that
my students ask me all the time I don't
quite know how to answer how do you
quantify the difference between an
electronic score and an acoustic score
in terms of what they are hearing how do
you tell people what to listen for I
mean it listening to to the howard score
what I heard was the reverb was
different and that some of the attacks
on the percussion in particularly the
horns and some definition in the strings
but you know is there is there something
more is there something that you can
hear that says this is the acoustic
version and this is why it's superior
you're asking the question that I wanted
to ask you because we this is a very
funny thing about market research when i
was working on the miyazaki picture
Ickes delivery service all those things
i was therefore called as music
supervisor because I
doing some composing but also I was just
creating a new score and working with
marketing people at Disney I discovered
something very interesting you know
we're not writing the scores and
producing the movies we won we're trying
to find out what you want and one of the
things about marketing in the United
States is they know a lot about what you
want most at least if you were 13 to 26
and then it's interesting to me from the
demo that James Newton Howard did the
first version that you heard he wasn't
pitching it towards anything he was
selling it to one person only to the
director right so he was making a
version that sounds good on a home
system a very good home system by the
way right but the version that the final
dubbed version included all of those
other elements like dialogue and so
forth and decisions being made when to
duck the music and so forth and
therefore the those the parameters of
the score then are going to be mixed by
all kinds of other considerations
dramatic ones that the composer didn't
have to worry about when he was making
his in effect a pitch to the director I
don't know if that answers your question
entirely I think I thought the question
was targeted more towards in years
wasn't it yeah i think that from my
perspective it gets harder all the time
to tell the difference as the technology
gets greater vienna strings for instance
is a software program where not only can
you get the strings you know playing
every note but they also now have it so
that you can get this the violin for
instance moving from the D to the a flat
because rather than just programming in
a D and then an A flat you can get the
transition to it which if you don't have
that difference you can definitely hear
that on an electronic score vs an
acoustic score but but as these things
get better it's harder I mean you know
they're my ears aren't as good as they
used to be but I could tell the
difference between an acoustic score
between something that was recorded on
an SSL or an eve board and the Neve is
always a warmer sound and so that's what
I that's how I kind of it's a hard thing
to describe and to quantify as you've
requested
that difference but it's a warmer sound
and but less warm all that what i should
say is it acoustic sounds always worn
but the electronic sound is getting
closer as they're as they're improving
it and as this producer on Star Trek
said on television nobody that matters
is going to be able to tell the
difference and unfortunately that's true
I wanted to ask you in the audience when
you heard the version with the demo and
then the version with the orchestra
could you tell a big difference between
the sound between a digital Orchestra
which is by the way real acoustic
instruments you know there's no we say
synthesizer that's not quite right this
is beyond the end days of analog on
things were created by wave shaping you
know clarinet being a triangle wave or
something like that the sound source is
all acoustic to begin with so I'm do you
see a big difference in your ears
between the digital orchestra and the
acoustic Orchestra and then if you do
hear the difference when we when the two
not we but when they mix together the
two deep what do you hear do you hear
analog and electric or do you hear
something else I'll tell you what I
please let's stop for a minute let's
let's have a show of hands how many of
you did here is strong difference
between two and three good well which
did you prefer how many preferred the
digital and how many prefer the what do
we call the other the other ocean aletta
coos well they kick up combined I guess
oh do you mean the the question to
mountain to me is how many prefer the
combined to the straight acoustic or
vice versa okay that's a separate
question okay but that's really hard to
quantify that is hard to quantify
because that focus that budget is
obviously but that's part of the
original design when we do scores now we
know we're going to have the demo
version of the digital and the acoustic
and that you were going to do the final
mix with the two well right so which did
you prefer there I I'm kerrison of what
you liked I don't know if you can be
able to find that out unless you go
around and ask each of them
in a sense that they probably want to
hear them again in order to to be more
jute I asked that question at the
electro-acoustic seminar of Han stoush
coo at Harvard on Monday and this is a
small seminar there were only 18 and
maybe there were 12 students in the
number of guests and this was a very
like MI tía you know there's thats cool
car harvard there and there they were
and these are very advanced graduate
students in electric who they were
talking about lots of things that are
way beyond anything that i know and
beyond what we do in Hollywood but they
were curious to know what we did in and
I played the very same thing to the end
they said something that I was actually
gratified first of all they thought that
the demo our sister was fabulous you
know without the acoustic but when we
combined the two the term that Hans to
schmooze said he was a good German
student of disciple of stockhausen you
know an aircon graduate and darmstadt he
said he said that's a super orchestra we
know that it's not it's straight
acoustic orchestra by the way in in
Hollywood we're not trying to fool you
we're trying to create something else
something you know whatever you were
talking about the slide from DDA flat
didn't you tell me Paul the other day
that now you get you can go in and
sample each note making an illusion so I
wanted to say when he mentioned that the
nsstring seema that's really from the
Vienna symphony and they went and last
week the London Symphony was in New York
I worked with them many times when I was
working for ITV and BBC in London they
were at the orchestra choice and so they
were friends of mine and I went out to
dinner after the concert in which they
did all prokofiev and they were talking
about this very thing because just
before leaving London they had sampled
they had subjected themselves to a
halloween sampling session for a company
called notion which whatever ebuddy will
be able to buy or steal soon and and
they had to sign a contract in a waiver
and so forth then Andrew Mariner that's
neville marriner sir neville marriner
son and the principal clarinet was
saying to me I was against it I told my
colleagues don't sign it we're giving
away our lives I mean our business I
said Andrew if you didn't sign it you're
giving away your your careers what they
did was all of these sampling
so I no longer just sampling a chromatic
scale you know you think you use sample
d and a plan by the way DNA flat never
occurs in Hollywood sleep it's no more
minor chords it's the fundamental inner
girl in psycho disc or psycho so anyway
the when we do sampling some when
sampling sessions are done now it isn't
just getting the pitches but every
possible in once within that pitch
whether it's legato and you have to
sample every orchestra for example a
diminuendo and a trumpet is very
different from the menu and on a violent
just acoustically speaking and attack is
different if you're going from one note
to another legato or staccato or
whatever all of those things are done so
any two chromatic pitches can have like
a hundred different sampling choices and
that's what a real thorough session is
and I mentioned that because in
Hollywood now when a big budget picture
comes along the composer creates his
orchestra first he samples everything I
wanted to show you if we have time blood
diamond in which the orcs is primarily
percussion because it was set in African
that was a choice he made but the
orchestra is set before even one note is
composed before a tune is composed
before they even spot the picture and so
that the sample orchestra is that you
can get now they're very expensive like
the Vienna strings or perhaps this
London Symphony and so forth no
Hollywood composers like hans zimmer at
remote control james alan silvestri
would use those everybody tweaks as we
say these sounds tana mates your
orchestra and that's one fundamental
difference with the new technology from
the the benchmark of say the hollywood
studio era where the the given sound was
the romantic park astre with large
strings winds in you know the wind
ensemble and the wind the complement of
brass and percussion that was the basic
sound now if you listen carefully to
those scores from the 30s and 40s you
can hear that they've already modernized
them tremendously there are banjos and
guitars in there there are pianos and
all over the place there's ila phones
things at Celeste Mack Steiner loves the
ping of the vibraphone kind of sound but
so even then but there was a bait there
was a baseline sound
but now it sounds like what happens is
the composer starts by creating his own
baseline of sounds before even writes
the music when I first I'm old enough
and therefore fortunate enough to have
come into the studio system Paul it was
just in his dying days but they were
still there so that the orchestra that I
first conducted in 1975 the concert
master was an old Viennese Jewish guy
named Arnold noi felt and this guy came
because he's concertmaster that the
Budapest a staatsoper and he played with
the sound that maybe Fritz Kreisler
might have played but if you want to
hear wonderful string orchestra playing
listen to The Hollywood scores from that
era 30s and I fell in love with that in
that music the music added the music
supervisor at Universal was Rudolph
rimmel the third in other words either
basically expatriate classical people
from that great Romantic era that Europe
managed to destroy in two world wars all
of that culture came to Hollywood so far
from feeling bad about working in
Hollywood I felt wonderful i felt like i
was finding something that I wouldn't
find if I went to Europe Europe at that
same time was rebuilding and therefore
distancing themselves certainly in
Germany distancing themselves from the
music that they had so proudly created
in the last two centuries have you ever
seen a German version of the Ring of the
knee Bolivian go to Los Angeles you see
a horrendous production I know everybody
thinks I'm him jerk for saying that but
the new the new production it's terrible
all right i want to see breastplates
with I here well I understand and I
sympathize but we're going to move away
from that topic I'm not a fascist I want
to see it Bhagat actually who else has a
question is anybody going to go to the
mic somebody is here question number of
the Tim Jackson I uh I've worked on a
number john sayles films with Mason
daring Lenny phone and that's um you
need a composer I'm just the drummer as
they say but a lot of those cues are
done right to picture because it can all
be done we just sit in the studio watch
the movie and play the queue and figure
out a click track that's certainly how
Mike post does law and order I've been
at his Christ ok so just last week so
yeah so that's one
question is what is what is how
prevalent is that kind of composing now
where you're just in a home studio
you're watching it you put your cue in
your done i mean sales works that way on
the top players did you do you have when
you're doing that a lot of times it's
just bass drums and guitar well isn't
that a part of it isn't it why it's
possible to do if you have a full
orchestra you can't no do that sort
right right but then my other question
is and I think about Danny Elfman who
starts in you know Boinga Boinga or
whatever on go born go I remember that
then very well did mystic Knights of the
angle boi Ingo he lived in Denison
exactly and there was sort of a stigma
on him composing for movies because he
was just a rock and roll guy now he does
these lush soundtracks but he has an
orchestra orchestrator often Jonathan
sheffer I think his orchestra different
things how often does that happen in the
process well most of the big-name
composers now our rock people have you
noticed I mean all the orchestrators
well I'm not an Orchestrator I mean
i-i've always orchestrated my own music
but I'm classically trained you know
Nadia Boulanger all that stuff the
composer's now like Hans Zimmer James
Newton Howard Alan Silvestri they're all
basic to come in and of course danielle
pan come from the world of rock and roll
and they have their orchestrators i'll
say something about Danny it's true the
stories you hear about some of these
composers is true some of them do not
know how to notate some of them do not
have that kind of formal training but
one thing about Danny's music is that it
always sounds like Alckmin and i like
that i like his music it's true his
orchestration sounds to me more like
sebelius the knowing Bob lingo but the
tunes are always Danny Elfman don't you
think I think well he didn't he didn't
he never did orchestrate and early on he
was surely Walker who was a very
talented composer and orchestra in
Hollywood that Hans also you had a lot
of these people when they first came in
they had to find his Paul is saying they
had to find orchestrators to make it
sound like film music but they did bring
a new sense of in the case of Danny I
would say artistry with Hans I wouldn't
say artistry I'd say it's more about
sound but but certainly they were
bringing their being innovative you know
Paul has talked about the history really
is is that these early composers in film
scoring were classically trained came
from the not only the European tradition
came from Europe and then the ones that
started to follow them also were trained
along those lines but then you went into
the Jazz period where a lot of the
people like Elmer Bernstein for instance
John Williams is one of the the last of
the hangers-on Mancini yeah Hank Mancini
Jerry fielding all these people that had
had come through the the big bands and
then they moved into filmmaking and then
after that in the 70s and 80s you
started to get the rockers you got Jack
Nietzsche was one of the early guys
miles Goodman and and the guy at NYU IRA
newborn and then along comes Danny and
people who follow so we're kind of in
that with the most popular rock carter
burwell yes Carter Thomas new hungry
actually had right right yeah right but
if I could just just attempt to make a
comment on on this question in terms of
the of the the process that that it's
unusual Mason daring as a pal of mine
too he actually teaches at at Berklee
College of Music and not very many
composers work in that method anymore
and I'll bet that you've worked with him
for a while other yards yeah right
exactly well yeah so you know like 70
years right so Mason's a really talented
picture by the way congratulations yeah
but when when you have people that play
together that long it's the old 10,000
hours thing you know the Beatles played
a long time the Liverpool before you
ever heard them so or I ever heard them
we so anyway it takes a certain
sensibility to be able to do that in a
room when I've seen it done that way
it's usually the composer will come in
with some court ideas or maybe a melody
and what not and then people just jam a
bit and then they look at the picture
and try and get into a groove well what
happens that's how Hans works only he
just does it with himself well let me
take that back if ever there was an
incorrect statement made in this
building that was it Hans doesn't do
anything by himself
except he'll take the meeting by himself
and he's one of the great meeting guys
of all time but you know like Penny
Marshall won't turn on her radio unless
she calls Hans and asked how to do it he
has a way of making people really rely
on him and trust him but when he's
sitting down and doing work that's what
he does a lot of the composer's work
that way now they don't go by timing
notes use timing notes anymore yeah see
so in the old days music adders would
prepare timing notes and given to the
composer and that's what they would
write to they wouldn't be looking at any
Victor picture they will have seen it
they at the spotting session and then
they don't get to see it again until the
scoring session and they were just from
typed out notes of saying you know at
zero 1.3 seconds into the queue cut to
the gun and that's how you know given
your rhythm well I need to you know that
the the third eighth note here is going
to have to catch that cut so that's
where the trumpets going to come in
that's not that's very rarely done now
what they do is they just put it up and
they start add living to it and try and
figure it out from that way that's the
basic track that's laid down first to
picture and that in effect guarantees
the sink that you want without having to
catch clicks to catch cuts or streamers
or any of those things I was a
classically trained conductor and music
schools you know so that I was one of
those people that could actually I could
do a whole scene with a stick with an
orchestra without clicks and without
streamers and things I was considered a
wonderful conductor that's a lost its I
don't want to see it's a lost art it's
an unnecessary art so when I teach music
now to filmmakers I don't teach the
skills that I painfully learned because
they're not necessary and it takes time
away from learning the skills that you
must know now such as would you probably
we have a question but i wanted i bring
up educational issues a little bit but
why don't we take a question hi I'm
Jason Jordan I actually seen your sound
designer over at sauna box so I'm kind
of part of the enemy because i made the
complete symphonic orchestral collection
with the boston symphony orchestra a lot
of hans uses it you know in all his
movies but one of the questions that I
had for you was at what point are you
really starting scoring I mean it is it
starting in the spotting session or
nowadays you're actually getting the
story and like
coming up with ideas and themes before
you've even seen any part of the picture
and then you know basically taking those
ideas putting it to picture moving your
timing sections around to you know
create you're seeing that probably was
the case with it's a good question but I
guess I doubt there's a fixed answer
because as you as you just pointed out
that probably was the way Jackson worked
with shore I'm King Kong and then no
score from shore so three weeks later
James Newton Howard has a new score so
all those notes but that's certainly a
long-term issue because it goes back to
the early days yeah the process you're
the very good question I can get the I
can't answer the question like I could
some other thing by but simply
reiterating what you just said the
process changes with the with technology
especially and remember the directors
themselves are younger now the directors
I the age of some of the students here
you know so that it is in the old days
old us old guys sort of directed young
it's not that way anymore everybody has
his own fluid way of interacting with
the coworkers yeah man probably knows
some stories along let me just say that
my sense is when you read accounts by
composers a lot of them say that they
start jotting ideas down well before the
actual scoring but until the spotting
sessions there's a limit to what they
can do right i mean they well that's
true and in fact i've talked with
several folks that tell me that that
they're not even having spawning
sessions anymore they'll just category
you know yeah because because because
they'll ship them you know a real or a
scene that has some temp music in it and
say you know here you can start working
on this here's what we had we kind of
like this here's what I liked about the
queue that's there and here's what I
don't like about it and and go and so it
isn't you don't have that very formal
structured meeting that involved the
director the composer the film editor
and the music editor to sit in the room
and go back and forth and talk about it
and where is the exact good spot for the
music to answer and what not those
decisions generally are made now by the
music editor who gives me to the
director and the director doesn't like
the the start or the cue tells me to get
it that
changed or the film editor by the way a
lot of film editors try to put
themselves we didn't need to met the
film editor is the music editor now so
the last two features i did with sydney
i didn't have a music editor we there is
a music editor listed in the credits but
that's that person who assembled
everything at the end for the dub for
the mix you know brought down where the
MIT logged where the stems are and all
the sort of technical stuff so we called
that person the music editor in the old
days that would have been the assistant
to the music editor so I have a question
for both of you then you talked about
what you want to train your students to
do and you're over at Berkeley would you
then as an exercise now give your
students cues from films and say go out
and write the same queue in a different
way to prepare them for the temp track
problem yeah and do they and so what do
you look for from them I mean how do you
help them become composers of other
people's music if you know any well the
thing that we emphasize and a couple of
our students are here now so they can
yell at me if I'm wrong but that the
thing that you have to keep in mind and
this is this is what separates film
composers from you know strictly
symphonic composers is that it's not
it's not about your music I mean your
music is not as important as the film
it's about the film and so you are just
one more element in a film but but it
you can write the most beautiful piece
of music that the world has ever heard
but if it doesn't fit in 33 seconds on
that particular q you can't say the film
to the director you know this piece of
music it's 47 seconds and it's just so
great just give me some more footage now
I know composer does that so so what you
have to do as a writer's the composer's
you have to make it fit there and it has
to it has to please the director and the
director can be a complete [ __ ] and
when the director says listen make it
more green you have to make it more
green whatever the hell that means and
so we that does is the kind of things we
tell the students and so what it's one
of the classes that I like that we do is
I team teach a class with an with Don
welcomes two former chair and we have
students do this kind of exercise and
then he and I
will comment and sometimes will disagree
as whether they did a good job or not
not good in that sense but did they did
they hit the nail on the head or did
they go too far did they not go far
enough you know will disagree about that
so just as every director will disagree
on what you as a composer turn in so
it's it's you know this tricky it's not
black and white you know so we can talk
about the educational things i have a
new approach to teaching my film
students something now I don't give
exercises like I tell me what you think
I make I take the the stoop of the film
composer student and marry them so to
speak to a filmmaker from the film
department or AFI or something and
instead of having them right Q's they
have to do the whole picture now that's
right because what I'm beginning to
realize now is that you don't write
individual cues you know it used to be
that we the love scene your love music
or chase senior but now we begin to
realize music as you say is part of the
drama so the important thing now is to
conceptualize how you want the music to
operate so now my latest and i don't
know how whether i'm going to be
successful or not but what do you think
that no I think you're absolutely right
that a film in and this is a problem
that you get into whether your temp
tracking or you're just writing cues
scene by scene a film score has to have
the same kind of emotional arc that a
that a plot has in its its journal it's
drama so that realistically if I can
take a cue from real nine and and make
it work in real three there's something
long the music right yes it and so you
have to keep that in mind as you as you
as you're looking at these things and as
you're designing it and and so what
we're doing along your lines we I don't
have that that the films excuse me a
film makers program at Berkeley so we've
gone over to Emerson oh and Boston both
exactly that's where we have yeah and
we're welcome if you guys know
filmmakers here we're trying to line up
some of our advanced students with
people that are having short films for
this for this reason and also for a lot
of reasons second reason learning how to
collaborate is so essential to the
process and finally networking shouldn't
start when you graduate no you have to
start now you have
you need to be building networks of
people that are going to help you find
work later well then and if you do a
good just to finish sorry but if you if
you for instance you score a film for a
student project and that gets even
nominated for an award and then you get
to go there and somebody says you know I
really like the music in that well yeah
the director says oh well it just so
happens that Sheila over here scored it
here meet Sheila and now Sheila is
expanding her network with a director
that she wouldn't have met otherwise so
that that's the other advantage of doing
this so yeah that's the way to go what I
wanted to say was remember I said
earlier that this is a brave new world
then it's yours and I pointed to the
young people well everybody in this room
is younger than I but anyway what I'm
saying is that because of the networking
that the computer has given to us
students there I don't have to have my
UCLA film a composition students work
only with UCLA people students from USC
now we may be rivals and football or
basketball we certainly are not in the
film world you know their kids at USC
their kids at Chapman University was a
nice Christian University down the road
that put out all these really wild
movies you know nothing about pedophilia
I think not just joking and and we have
but you know and afi and and who knows
and I know my students are saying I
heard from this kid from from NYU now
that's the other in the Bible but they
send this you know you can say so this
network does happen and it's really
gratifying instru one of my students we
just got a master's degree and hooked up
through this way with a picture that got
an Academy Award nomination in the in
the truth um that's right now we were
all astonished we didn't think he was
our best student you know just goes to
show you the matter what do we know in
school there listen there are plenty of
people that are working today that
aren't as talented you know I mean it's
true a lot of the time look how many
grey films whirring well we put out
about 60 or 70 films growing graduates
every year all right so and we have the
only film scoring program major in the
country but there's certainly a lot of
people studying film scoring who are
composition majors and who go out to
Hollywood so there are not that many
jobs
and and the people that get them get
them primarily through luck okay now you
have to be able to deliver you have to
have the talent but luck get you the job
luck as you're walking by in the door
opens luck as you go to a screening and
you meet somebody or you're at a party
and you meet somebody or somebodies
uncle works on a television show and
they introduce you to somebody I mean
luck plays a huge deal here so you have
to be ready when those opportunities
occur yeah but there's another thing you
know it's luck and hood spot that's a
it's like just yeah go for it lie into
whatever it takes and and you don't have
to have Jefferson know in our business
exactly right in our business we make
our opportunities well for you know
there are no studios just find somebody
and put out a picture and then yes what
no that's okay well you you could talk
about your own that's breaks the death
race 2000 yeah I had no training
whatever and I'm not Jewish but I got a
picture on my own and how i did it i am
now by the way but I mean that's what I
mean hood spy you know I was I was at
UCLA and I helped set up the electronic
music's to the analog electronic music
studio I was a friend of Robert moges I
went to Cornell and he was at Ithaca
alright so the first electronic music
score that anybody ever who talks about
is a clockwork orange right and and all
of a sudden everybody want an electronic
music score but I was tired of being at
UCLA so I quit and I got a phone call
like talk about luck you were saying and
it was a girl named Julie moldo who was
the assistant to a gun if named Robert I
mean Roger Corman and they were looking
for somebody and he said Julie said
they're we're looking for a graduate
student who can do some electronic music
for the science fiction picture doing
about this race that goes you know
killing people along the way and I said
I'll send my death student and I went
down myself and this is a true story if
you go to the Walk of Fame in Hollywood
you know where the stars Wilma yeah
let's start the kodak theatre it's that
story is there right now so and I went
down myself and he gave me a contract
for a thousand dollars i thought that
was my key it was my budget
so and he and he thought I was my own
student then picture was called death
race 2000 as I told a jump movie was the
first picture of another guy who was
running away from the draft superhero
called Sylvester Stallone II you know
and this picture became a cult favorite
for some reason and I'll say this about
Roger he may be a god of but he gave me
a career he gave me a full screen credit
you know and even though I made no money
I Honor this man he did the same for
Jack Nicholson and Francis Ford Coppola
and a hundred other people hundred times
more talented in famous than I but I'd
consider that honorable to give yourself
a true up give somebody a true
opportunity you want to talk Jan just a
minute about your fewer work with the
debate a thing that you were too or what
would the you have to explain sure if
there's not yeah I mean if somebody has
any other question I was thinking maybe
that was your luck story but I don't
know if it no well the yeah actually was
lucky I ran a company called Segway
music and we had about 25 it would range
depending on how much television we were
doing actually because television
requires more people and keeps you busy
ER but we would have between 25 and 30
people working all the time and in the
early 90s two of the music editor is
working for me that we're working on
features Curtis Roush and Chris Brooks
both Berkeley graduates by the way which
is how I first became aware of this
school I mean you know you have to think
that's kind of strange right i mean
films are identified filmmaking is
identified really with two cities in
America LA and New York and to somewhat
certain you know Chicago and they're
trying to get Plymouth Rock Studios
going and maybe maybe that'll happen
Boston a lot of films get shot in Boston
but it's not where all the work gets
done so that's that mainly LA and some
in New York and so the fact that the
film scoring program is set up at
Berkeley and not at NYU or UCLA now
Paul's doing that but or at SC seem
strange but anyway so here these two
guys working for me and they came to me
in the early 90s and they said Dan
there's going to be something called the
digital revolution and we
need to get in front of it and I had no
idea what they were talking about 450
years since nineteen twenty four so
actually actually 70 years huh yeah
music editing and sound editing had been
done primarily on the thing called
moviola which wasn't even it was created
actually somebody thought it would be
great to have to use in the home a way
to look at movies in the home and so
that was the tool that was used for all
those years but these guys had done some
research had been exposed to some stuff
that was going on and so they came to me
and said you only choice you have to
make is whether you want to beta test a
system called sound tools which is by
digidesign which grew to become pro
tools or sonic solutions which was a
more expensive system and was used more
for cleaning up tracks and so that's why
it was more expensive actually you take
out the sounds and needle scratches and
that sort of stuff which wasn't
necessary first because in the film
world you're recording in a pristine
environment so I I met with the folks at
digidesign and we set up this this some
good choice yeah yeah this beta tested
so the first so so what that led to
sound tools in the early 90s then became
pro tools and we wound up delivering the
first digital score from the scoring
stage to the dubbing stage which is
polishing the WH way that makes all the
the sound music sound and music editing
and sorry dialogue sound of music
together so that was a movie called last
action hero starring anyone anyone the
governor of California anyone and i have
to tell you those of you who are our
techies would appreciate the fact that
they hated us when we delivered this
stuff it was a you know it was not very
16-bit and another thing is is that the
digital for the pro tools allows you as
the operator to create your own cross
fades and
in Hollywood history that's always the
job of the mixer the guy that's sitting
the guy or gal that's sitting at the
panel and so that in the old days it
would come in on analog and you'd have
one real of music running out and
another one coming in and that's how you
get your segway and that and the mixer
would kind of move the knobs here to
make it nice and smooth so with the
digital film with the Pro Tools you were
able to do that yourself and that just
pissed them off royally it's like how
dare you so but it's come a long way
from there but but so that was how we
got involved in and and and the really
interesting thing about that as I said
because it lasted 70 years and then
within five years of that it became the
industry standard not that you know it's
not like we created I mean somebody
would have done it we were lucky to be
there but and that's the luck part and
and it was because of these two students
really because if it had been anybody
that I had trained or my father or had
come to a some other way they wouldn't
have had that information that's that's
a great story can i ask you did you have
anything to do with the money isn't
there a lot of Mozart floating around in
the background of the last action hero
score I remember seeing and thinking why
are they using Mozart's G minor or
something like you know i wish i could
tell you about that I Michael came and
did that score and Michael's not with us
anymore sadly but Curtis and Chris did
the actual music editing on that show so
I wasn't there for like a min is another
who also had a rock that's right we
didn't mention him and we should have
because he may be the premier guy from
that era Michael was a wonderful guy
really terrific does anybody else have a
question otherwise I all have some other
clips and I thought we should see at
least one or two of them if the people
are still up in the booth with the
machines up yo dude see you
what I want to talk a little bit about
my story because he all right Paul Paul
would like wait we do have a question so
is that Michael yeah Michael mom I'm
Michael Miller I'm a senior at MIT
majoring in music I had the opportunity
two years to go to intern for howard
shore which wasn't a great opportunity
but in working with him he had just
actually finished this kind of small
side project there was a Korean video
game company that was producing this
online game and they asked Howard Shore
to do the music for it which kind of had
this weird impact on me knowing about
this because first off it was a Korean
company asking him in New York and he
just he never even saw the video game he
was asking me if I knew Korean to go get
the you go access the game and play it a
little bit but I guess there's the
internal internationalization component
of everything that's I guess is
interesting because of Technology but
then on top of that how do you feel
about the interaction between film music
and this kind of newcomer video game
music which is becoming more and more
prominent that's well like yeah you want
to go first all right that's not only a
good question but it's an intimidating
question because that's the monster
that's swallowing up our industry video
games you know it's like if you had
talked to people in radio when
television first started and they would
have said talk the same way I am now
because we see this in its infancy
already swallowing us up I've never done
a video game I'd like to but that's
another in you know I've done 100 movies
I won't probably in my life then get one
game it's a whole different industry you
know and they have huge budgets there
and they don't do it digitally only they
do they will send you someplace you'll
have 100 piece orchestra and you provide
an hour's worth of music it's it's true
that music is often based on imitating a
Howard Shore score you know it if it's
not how it should be somebody who's
asked imitated you know but it's a huge
industry and for one of my colleagues
Laura Cartman who's a PhD from Juilliard
and abets student he teaches with me at
UCLA but now she's so busy because she's
been appointed head of the game music at
song
and at first it was a tiny gig not some
monster gig and she's a terrific
musician you know what do I feel about
it I feel that I wish I could get in
there and if you can help me out yeah
for those of you don't know more
people's people spent more money on
video games last year than any other
form of entertainment period more than
movies records you know that's that's
where it's happening and interesting the
actually we at Berkeley I'm not nuntin
to toot our horn but but I want to give
you an example of how powerful students
can be it just happens that that the
president of the video game music club
from Berkeley is here in the audience
today hello Philippe um are you the
here's what happened a year ago well a
year ago last fall so this is the fall
of 07 Filippo came to me and said you
know we formed this video music club we
have like 14 people and you know videos
what's happening and I and I already
have become aware of that because of my
work in Los Angeles Tommy Tallarico was
as somebody I'd collaborated with at the
motion picture carrots are at the
Recording Academy the Grammy
organization and that's where I learned
about you know the fact that they were
taking these things around the world
they have these huge concerts lasers and
interaction with the audience and
symphonies playing nothing but video
game music at concerts so I mean it's
really exploded i remember when Steve
Vai who's a famous guitarist and nile
rodgers a guy that I work on movies with
it also did we are family both extremely
wealthy and set for life and they came
to me about four years ago and said hey
we're doing the sim some video games and
i'm thinking i think you know pong when
somebody says video game music them all
jesus really too bad you know these guys
their careers must be going in the
toilets are talking to me about kids
games and stuff no not at all so really
lunch so anyway Filippo on his and his
compatriots came to me so that Club grew
from 14 to a hundred people within a
year and the interest was so great i was
able to go to the administration
convince them to let us hire a full-time
professor and build a new lab to
accommodate the video game music program
which we
which we started doing but once again
there it is i mean this this is a second
story i've told you now and it's true
that it's the impetus of students making
these demands and and we have to be
listening we have to be hearing what's
what's going on with changes are going
on so that we can help them prepare to
go out and work see i'm concerned about
the fact that as i said here's we've got
this film scoring program at Berkeley
and we're putting out 70 graduates or so
a year there aren't jobs for that for
all those people and I you know they're
paying money there folks are paying
money and and and they pick artistry as
a career in the in the only country in
the Western world that doesn't give a
[ __ ] about art and so it's really it's
no I'm serious about them it's awful
it's shameful when you go to Europe and
you see the respective is paid to
artists there compared to what happens
here it's it's night and day which is
why you had so many African American
jazz artists move to sweden and other
northern european countries and not ever
want to come back so so so here we have
this these people were training and and
i don't want them to go out and and not
have options and so that's one of the
reasons we felt it's important to get
the video game music program going so
that it would be one more option for
them to explore when they're out there
trying to find work you said that well
how many companies now control the video
game music area is it isn't is it aren't
the studio's getting into all of that
too there are no studios well i mean
they aren't the same collect ronic arts
and Philippe oak do you want to make a
comment on it can you answer that
question how does how is the Museo Mike
I mean this guy knows everything about
their stuff you know can you introduce
yourselves sure my name is Filippo I'm
as Dan said I'm the president of the
video game music club over at Berkeley
been working very hard to promote video
game music not only because it's a great
business as I'm sure all of you know but
also because there's a generation of of
people who grew up with video game music
by playing games obviously and the whole
musical aesthetic and perception of
music had changed by playing video games
um and I count myself in as being one of
these individuals since I've heard more
interactive music than I've heard linear
music for most parts of my life now
because I've been playing a lot of games
clearly and I think this is starting to
to influence young people on a level
that is clearly fundamental and we're
starting to see musicians that have been
there have been influenced by this music
from from very young age on so I feel
also that from an artistic standpoint
video games have to grow and have to
develop a new language that we're kind
of I feel getting help from film in a
lot of aesthetic choices and a lot of
storytelling choices we make the video
games can't really walk on themselves
still yet but games are an evolving
language and we have a it's a way of
growing that it's it's exciting to see
then we are starting to develop a whole
new language that will eventually not
have to imitate film and film music for
the end to be an artistic expression on
itself so if I could just interrupt the
the we had a panel at school last year
and made up Tommy Tallarico and and
Notre Hugo he was no he didn't yeah yeah
so um and and several other composers
and business executives from that world
and I asked what they thought the
percentage of scores for video games
were acoustic as opposed to electronic
because I had assumed that you know it's
like ninety percent electronic seventy
percent acoustic they're spending money
the budgets are better for music and
video games and they're in films now and
it's a different way of working to its
really interesting the collaboration is
different yes and if I can admit your go
ahead yeah the compose
additionally speaking as a composer and
a musician creating an interactive score
holds so many new challenges and so many
different directions that you have to
take because we're so used to film that
we know exactly what happens at a
certain moment and you know King Kong
will always come out that that's
specific minute and second and you know
it will be there but the considerations
that you have to make too poor to make
an interactive score where you don't
know when the player is going to meet
the monster or meet the enemy opens up a
whole new set of challenges that as a
composer I feel is incredibly exciting
to for everyone who is into composition
because it opens up a new new set of
challenges so there's an example of the
technology kind of driving right
continue the change in in the artistry
avant-garde in music in Germany actually
anticipated I wish stockhausen when he
introduced his turn intuitive music and
the Chairman at Harvard right now Hans
to sue is picking up on that so that you
see you said something really wonderful
you talked you drew a distinction
between linear and interactive music
what that also exists in certain places
in composition apps so we don't worry so
much now are you a twelve-tone composer
at Tom composite those are old it seems
to me old battles that work should never
have been fought right row talking about
the whole concept of what it is to be a
musician how it is or to be a little
closer or I'm closer performer but that
that that issue of the linear versus
interactive structures for music is a
problem that's compounded by the of you
it's very interesting to hear you say
it's an evolving language and we need
the new because and as is so often the
case with media and transition when you
go from one medium to another when film
emerged they copy there's your borrowing
and so forth you borrow but when we when
we look when i looked into video game
music even five to ten years ago I found
so little to listen to that I wanted to
listen to let alone the problem of
learning to be a game player I'm just
telling it this is a very personal
perspective
but for someone who grew up steeped in
the film narrative film film medium and
the idea of film is rich richly designed
narratives with layers of meaning that
are as rich as any other art form in
that of narrative style of a narrative
type where I where I had now a history
of hundreds of scores by great and not
so great composers that really
contributed a new way of approaching how
to write music for a for a narrative
rhyme specific film and then you look at
these things in and of course in those
days there were the problems of the
platform technology and though the
sounds were so deficient sure man now it
seems like within light with lightning
speed is growing everything is opening
up and there are unlimited possibilities
but it's respect but every three months
I see another article in the Phoenix or
someone that's a see unix reviewer who
says this is the citizen came a video
game I'm not helping the adverse already
it will though very soon if da years for
citizen k to be made and you know what
it took another 20 to 30 before people
even started to be able to see it right
my twin why numbers and think of it as a
great film and also they're jumping the
gun right and also the the whole
comparison I I can see where it stems
from but the nature of a game is
inherently different to a movie and
we're the game industry has been almost
desperately trying to convey the same
emotions as film is capable of doing but
in the end just like we say a composer
has to deliver a score and it's for the
movies for the story the game is for the
game you know the music is for the game
and the game is is completely different
it's a completely different form of
entertainment and completely different
form of art if you will then a movie and
I think instead of seeing it as a
weakness of of games we should see it as
a as a strong point of games but
it means seeing also music that you can
create four games under a different
light and not as something that you know
the film score is here and we're trying
to emulate it as much as possible well I
I understand i'm sorry i'm thinking
about this a lot and yeah i like to say
to people now you know games have been a
part of human culture forever forever
and what are the best games that have
been created up till now maybe chess
spin the bottle oh that's a good one
great okay maybe chest and maybe bridge
in terms of intellectual but can we ever
think of them as narratives that are
going to move us that are going to
reflect human experience I remain to be
convinced than video games for all their
economic clout for all the willingness
of people to spend years of their life
in front of a machine pretending reality
I remain to me yeah you send I'm afraid
that you're talking to yes we need to
repeat that I either you need to go to
the Michael I you might need what you
said watch out Filippo okay you better
sit down buddy this is starting to be
very tender sorry I was just asking if
you had ever played through a really you
know really high quality long good RPG
video game before because I wish that
people who you know make that kind of
argument would actually experience it
not because I think you know oh you
can't possibly make that argument but
just because I feel like it's like
saying that a symphony can never be
beautiful if you've never listened to an
entire symphony by my bed that's a
perfectly valid point if you would send
me some games to play and teach me how
to play them I know but delete believe
you me I can and I will
well but you know this is the this is
the whole issue of the and that's why it
is a generational issue I mean this is
this is we went when we were kids we
went to Saturday matinees you got to see
two features and and a cartoon or a
short in between and and so that was
that was a major form of entertainment
for this generation many of them that
what that is a major form of
entertainment is games and so that they
it's a different way of thinking about
things and the quality of music is
actually exploding I mean when Laura
Cartman is a major talent and then oh
and a number of people like bill Conti
you know who wrote rocky and all those
things right when the Academy Award for
him you know he did you haven't seen his
name lately he's doing games exclusively
Bruce brownton wrote the first
orchestral score for a video game yeah
so a lot of major composers who whose
credits and who's John he's doing one
yeah and by the way I don't share your
you're concerned for my students I mean
you saying that there are no jobs out
there of course their jobs out there
they'll make them them sell I'm saying
that there aren't 70 jobs out there if
I'm sending 70 graduates plus what
you're sending out plus what's coming
out of the other side you know look it's
supposing we're with the economy being
what it is there's nothing stable out
there you know no matter what business
here and you're going to graduate and
find it difficult I tell my students now
go for it you know might as well have
fun going going and you're more likely
to succeed and by the way here's an
interesting statistic I learned
something from you I didn't know you had
70 graduates you know how many students
our programs only two years old you know
many students I have mmm I'm 30 well i
hope the all graduate
I think it's getting to the point where
we're going to have to wind this up and
it's too bad that the question thanks to
Michael Miller for asking the question
because boy he really opened a very
lively issue that wasn't even in the
title you know you notice this wasn't
called film film and video game music in
the digital age it's a very good
question it is it is it's another topic
and it does need it does need much more
addressing I think one of the key points
that's come out here is this idea that
for some reason in spite of the maybe
precisely because of the the nature of
the video game medium they want the
acoustic sound they don't want digital
sound they don't want and this reminds
me of the whole the old thing about
animation that the great animation
composer Fred Steiner told me one day
when he said you know they know that
when you don't when you run animation
without music you see the frame you see
that you see that it's like King Kong in
the original 1933 you see him lurching a
you suddenly are aware of things that
you're not aware of when you add music
to the animation it makes it real or it
makes it more real and if there's a
there's a process of audio and vision by
the way together when I first went to
work for Disney I'd already been in the
film business a long time this was when
i was in kiki's delivery service the
first thing they said to me was we don't
do Foley here you're going to have to
provide everything with the music right
no that's an of course from video games
you have a lot of Foley you know because
it's a whole whole new kind of reality
this door similitude I don't even think
by the way I don't ask anymore is this
real you know whether were this is
because consent me it's all right
whatever it's seven buts so just a
complete that the idea that for a long
time what video games were clearly
emphasizing were sound design sound
effects and sound design over the
musical role because they hadn't solved
the problems very well of interactive
structures now they're clearly turning
to that and you're probably right and
I'm probably just hopelessly outdated
here
there will be major there will be major
breakthroughs very soon and we may not
know which ones are the really important
ones for a little while we that's my
only my only concern here is that people
are so quick now to hail the master
piece before without taking into
consideration that sometimes the really
good things are the things you don't
like or you don't understand at first it
takes more time for them to be
appreciated but I want to use that word
appreciation as the segue to our exit
and thank via and I also should announce
there's a now how do I do that there's a
reception reception at a dorm on the
campus down the street it's called
senior house you can follow some of us
if you'd like to come along its it will
directly follow this and so you will
have a chance to say hello and complain
to me and talk to them but I want to
express my appreciation to dan carlin
and Paul chihara for coming from across
the river and across the country to our
symposium and thank you very much as an
audience thank you to Selena thank you
very much
you
you